des clés pour comprendre lui mais
risation de notre économie son impact
sur les métiers et l'emploi et pour
lancer le débat je vous propose un
extrait du reportage long format qui
avait été diffusé sur public sénat
intitulé l'argent du beurre signé fabien
becker et notamment ces manifestations
de chauffeurs de livreurs ceux que l'on
surnomme les prolétaires 2.0
nous sommes payés à la tâche
le temps d'attenté au restaurant le
temps qu'on m'ait coup quitté de notre
position au restaurant il n'est pas pris
en compte en un an j'ai dit rehn et le
prix des coups ç'a été divisé
pratiquement part-dieu
complètement héros partants ont donné à
manger
c'était sont livrés des
motos de confinement est terminé
maintenant des restaurants ouverts comme
par hasard ça coïncide avec des dépôts
des stades et enceintes et des gens
sympas on se sent tout petit con
j'ai fait du compte des esclaves parce
que quand tu y travailles quand même
à l'image de ses livres à ravello des
millions de travailleurs dans le monde
oeuvre aujourd'hui pour des plateformes
numériques
des start-up devenus des géants comme
hubert ou des livres qui ont recours à
des travailleurs indépendants rémunérés
à la tâche sans contrat de travail est
souvent sans protection sociale
une bataille est engagée des élus des
avocats des travailleurs tentent de
s'opposer aux excès de l'ubs et risation
ce modèle social économie s'extrait de
la responsabilité sociale qu'est celle
des commerçants des artisans des
entreprises c'est un modèle aussi qui
comment dire
des humanistes complètement la relation
de l'activité mais leur combat est loin
d'être gagné car l'univers des
plateformes numériques s'étend désormais
à toutes sortes de métiers
libéralisation un ennemi qui vous veut
du bien évidemment c'est une question
qu'on pose à l'occasion de ce débat
j'accueille hervé novelli vont soir à ça
bienvenue vous êtes président de
l'association des plateformes
d'indépendants ancien secrétaire d'état
évidemment au commerce à l'artisanat aux
pme c'était au sein du gouvernement
fillon vous êtes à l'origine de la mise
en place du statut d'auto entrepreneur
s'est éteint en 2009 sarah des lourds
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes sociologue
du travail spécialiste du capitalisme de
plateformes voilà une nouvelle
spécialité qui n'existait pas il ya
quelques années et vous avez dirigé
l'ouvragé les nouveaux travailleurs des
applis avec dominique méda c'est aux
presses universitaires de france olivier
jacquin bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi vous êtes sénateur ps de meurthe
et moselle et membre de la mission
d'information urbanisation de la société
quels impacts des plateformes numériques
sur les métiers et l'emploi qui vient de
dévoiler 18 recommandations et
évidemment rentrera dans le détail de
certaines d'entre elles notamment sur la
question des algorithmes et ses teintes
et des uns des thèmes qui est vraiment
très intéressant et puis en
visioconférence avec nous denis jacquet
qui est entrepreneur fondateur de
l'observatoire de libéralisation bonsoir
denis jacquet je vous ai piqué le titre
de votre livre qui était publié chez sa
maîtresse des bahuts veritas y ont un
ennemi qui vous veut du bien voilà je
jeu rend à césar ce qui lui ce qui lui
appartient les dix siècles pas
évidemment il est resté à nos côtés
peut-être une petite définition hervé
novelli pour commencer c'est quoi
libéralisation d'abord c'est un propre
parce que
libéralisation c'est ça vient du ber wii
et wii u hubert en tout cas c'est ma
conviction ne ne résume pas à lui seul
set ce phénomène c'est un phénomène très
simple en fait un phénomène qui est née
de la révolution numérique et qui permet
à travers une application de faire se
rencontrer rahim de tout le monde une
offre avec une demande et donc dès lors
que la demande peut rencontrer l'offre
avec une application sur un smartphone
est bien le phénomène de places de
marché c'est-à-dire là où justement on
peut faire se rencontrer offre et
demande est en marche et
c'est la logique que cette révolution
technologique
puisse permettre cette plateforme
isation de l'économie c'est sans doute
ça va au delà c'est autre chose au delà
du statut des bien sûr ou des chauffeurs
bien sûr plus que l'offre l indre et
vous de bien moindre coût parce que
c'est ça aussi les avantages pour tout
le monde oui enfin on va en discuter
mais le un simple exemple chiffré pour
montrer que hubert et les plateformes
dites de mobilité ne réduisent pas ne
résume pas le débat il ya aujourd'hui en
france environ sur la mobilité à peu
près cent mille travailleurs dans ses
plates formes de conflits c'est à dire
on suivra aussi les derniers chiffres
les derniers chiffres de la mission ray
c'est c'est officiel en tout cas c'est
ce qui m'a dit
le démentent donc il ya cent mille
travailleurs en gros dans les vtc et à
la livraison et puis il ya cent mille
autres travailleurs dans les plateformes
soit de services à la personne
vous savez combien il ya de coiffeurs
professionnels sur wii casa plateforme
qui fait se rencontrer des clients avec
des coiffures 45 esthétique parce que 45
milles et donc vous voyez les chiffres
donc il ya les plateformes de services à
la personne il ya les plateformes de
services aux entreprises et donc le
phénomène sur lequel on se focalise et à
mon avis à tort bon est ce que ça ne
concerne qu'une minorité accord il ya
quand même en france un million et demi
d'un auto entrepreneur il ya 200 milles
sous statut d'indépendant dans les
plateformes vous voyez les chiffres 3
millions et demi d'indépendants et trois
millions de ses débuts mitigés de la
peur ni les chiffres 2019 selon l'urssaf
3 million deux cent mille 2 indépendants
sarah des lourds
vous parlez de deux nouveaux esclaves en
quelque sorte c'est presque vous avez
presque jusque là on parle des
prolétaires 2.0 une société de la
servitude voilà le terme que vous
employez oui alors effectivement je
pense pas qu'on utilise et celui de
l'absurde utile et les travailleurs dans
leur mobilisation qui peuvent s'estimer
être esclave des applications au vu de
leur énorme dépendance
vis-à-vis des applications au vu des
contraintes exercées sur leurs
conditions de travail le fait qu'ils ne
choisissent pas leurs tarifs qui ne
choisissent pas la manière dont ils
travaillent qu'ils sont contrôlés qui
peuvent être sanctionnés tout ce qui a
été pris en compte aussi dans les
décisions de justice qui ont amené à
l'heure aux qualifications comme comme
salarié mais là quand vous parlez de ça
ça concerne qui ça concerne uniquement
les métier de chauffeur de livres house
et du maire général ce alors j'ai plutôt
parler de plateforme isation course je
vais pas essayer employer un terme a été
celui qui est proposé d'ailleurs par la
mission d'information est ce que ça
concerne finalement tous eu tous ces
travailleurs indépendants ou auto
entrepreneurs qui qui participent à la
plateforme isation en fait effectivement
pourrait un peu élargir le sujet et en
revenir aussi à à nouveau une paternité
d'hervé novelli puisque ray c'est plus
largement depuis que le régime de l'auto
entrepreneur elle mis en place et qui a
une incitation extrêmement forte à la
mise à son compte qu'on a découvert
quand même aussi enfin qu'on a incité un
continent de salariat déguisé qui
travaillent faussement sous statut
d'indépendant puisqu'avec les auto
entrepreneurs et les principaux usagers
du dispositif ce sont les employeurs qui
vont l'utiliser comme modalités de
recrutement comme modalités de
rémunération ça veut pas dire qu'il ya
pas certain qu'ils sont des andes et
vraie démarche de création d'activité
mais quand on les rencontre en fait ce
sont enfin c'est vraiment une minorité
et donc les peler plateforme elles sont
venu s'insérer dans ce mouvement de
contournement du salariat par
l'indépendance en organisant le travail
exclusivement sous statut
d'auto-entreprise vieja qu'un vous
proposer d'inscrire une présomption de
salariat tout à fait pourquoi tout à
fait et bien ce qu'a oublié de dire mon
ami novelli c'est que effectivement la
plateforme isation vient de technologies
numériques vient de ce que vient de dire
l'excellente sarr abdennour de
dérégulation dans le statut du travail
mais encore de la présomption
d'indépendance qui est donné depuis 2009
fillon aux travailleurs des plateformes
et tac en réfléchissant en travaillant
fortement sur le sujet j'ai proposé une
proposition de loi qui était présenté
dans l'hémicycle en mai disant tiens on
n'a qu'à faire linverse puisque la cour
de cassation dit qu'il y à des
indépendants fictifs on est dans un état
de droit eh bien on n'a qu'à dire que
ils sont résumées salarié s'il s'agit de
vrais indépendants les plateformes
sauront le dire et les choses seront
bien plus clair l'espagne vient de le
faire et alors là je suis très content
même le parlement européen le 16
septembre
vient de prendre une résolution c'est
une rapporteur en marche en
disant eh bien la présomption de
salariat pourrait être une solution
intéressante pour clarifier ce paysage
vous rendez compte qu'avec le statut
d'auto entrepreneur certaines
plateformes j'en connais une mehdi flash
exploite la pénurie de travailleurs
hospitaliers et je connais une
infirmière en hôpital qui est
auto-entrepreneur
je connais aussi avec la plateforme
staff me un garçon de café 15 ans
d'expérience boulevard saint germain son
patron l'a convaincu il s'est convaincu
de devenir auto-entrepreneur manque de
bol c'était début 2000 vas tu j'ai
rappelé après le premier confinement il
pleurait il a eu droit à rien puisqu'il
avait démissionné et on l'a mis dans la
misère totale mais si c'est ça la
plateforme isation je n'en veux pas
alors du salariat dans certains cas et
puis lorsqu'ils sont des vrais
indépendant il faut améliorer leur
statut le gouvernement nous emmène dans
une voie intermédiaire insidieuse dans
lequel il veut tenter dire tiens
regardez les livreurs à vélo les vtc
c'est un peu spécial on pourra en faire
quelque chose d'intermédiaire entre le
salariat et le statut d'indien reviendra
sur ce que propose le gouvernement je
sais pas si denis jacquet
nous nous entend de nouveau on avait un
petit point de liaison denis jacquet
vous nous écoutez depuis le début de ce
débat et est ce que vous vous défendez
alors je vais utiliser le terme français
la plateforme isation malgré
effectivement ce qu'on peut entendre la
nécessité d'une régulation est ce que
malgré tout encore aujourd'hui vous
dites c'est c'est un progrès c'est un
facteur de croissance pour notre
économie
en fait le problème la raison pour
laquelle on avait monté l'observatoire
de l'ubs et risation nous c'est en 2016
si on commence aujourd'hui avoir des
rapports
sénatoriaux ou parlementaire on commence
à voir madame bornes qui a fait une
énième consultation bon nous on avait
commencé il ya cinq ans je rappelle
juste que hubert même si on doit pas
réduire le discours là dessus a
aujourd'hui a été créée en 2009 donc on
voit bien que le temps de la société le
temps des consommateurs et le temps de
la politique et des gouvernements n'est
pas le même donc la société évolue
beaucoup plus vite dans ses bons et ses
mauvais côtés que le reste de la société
donc ça c'est le premier truc en fait je
pense que il ya si je puis me permettre
d'être un peu mais thomas me connais un
peu énervé aussi mais d'être un petit
peu un petit peu brusque je pense que
les courses que j'ai entendu avant du
monsieur le sénateur des douanes de
madame sur la sociologie du capitalisme
1 on est en train alors le jeu citerai
marx pour qui l ultime réussite d'un
système de lutte serait l'indépendance
donc c'est assez amusant de comprendre
aujourd'hui indépendant serait une
nouvelle forme de précarisation donc
marx considérait que c'était au
contraire l'aboutissement d'un combat
mais c'est autre chose mais la première
chose c'est un on dit voilà c'est plate
forme ont précarisé alors déjà c'est
assez avoir mal étudié le sujet parce
que comme le rappelait hervé et a
énormément de plate forme aujourd'hui et
je peux vous citer un nombre de
plateformes incalculables l'observatoire
quasiment toutes dans lequel les
indépendants gagne beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup mieux leur vie que quand il
était salarié et surtout à l'époque avec
ipsos experte en a fait des sondages une
année deux années trois années donc on a
des chiffres vraiment très précis mais
quand on disait montebourg à l'exception
j'y reviendrai des vtc est ce que vous
voulez continuer à être indépendant ou
est ce que voulait retourner au salariat
jusqu'à 82% les gens vous disent aimer
je veux rester indépendant donc du coup
il ya une espèce de boboïsation
parisienne ou du dogmatisme
politique qui voudrait déjà qui aidera à
dire car ça date de quand ces chiffres
là sur ces chiffres m'ont dit on les a
faits en
2016-17 on l'a versé à nouveau en 2018
on n'a pas fait 2019 et 2020 mais je
suis prêt à ces prêts à paris
aujourd'hui sauf qu'au vide évidemment
qu'il faut c'est un petit peu les choses
que les chiffres seraient mous serait à
peu près à peu près les mêmes
aujourd'hui parce que on se focalise
toujours sur ces deux professions
livreurs et vtc mais hervé le rappeler
aujourd'hui il ya plusieurs centaines de
plate-forme en france mais justement si
vous allez voir les esthéticiens soit
laissé à certaines parties des services
à la personne des consultants etc il y
en a aucun qui veut revenir dans un
région de saint jacques et un jour
prendre je reprends la main je voudrais
que
ça va vous puissiez réponse ad nous
perdons sur cet argument c'est à dire
que là on est vraiment sur deux visions
assez assez opposées denis jacquet nous
dit mais le ce statut cette plateforme
isation elle fait le bonheur de milliers
voire de dizaines de milliers d'anciens
salariés alors déjà est-ce que je peux
revenir sur l'évocation de la figure de
marque parce que c'est vrai que c'est
hervé novelli aime bien aussi essayer de
retourner mars contre des gens qui sont
plutôt deux défenseurs d'un du modèle
social je pense que c'est quand même
vraiment un contrôle
oui mais alors ces départs d'hervé
novelli le québec n'était pas favorable
était pas favorable aux salariés du 19e
siècle et faire la comparaison
aujourd'hui c'est faire fi de 150 ans
d'histoire par exemple lesquels le
salariat est devenu aussi le socle de la
protection sociale premièrement et
deuxièmement marx son bonheur ne serait
pas réalisé par la chute du salariat par
l'avènement de l'auto entreprenariat
mais bien par la collectivisation des
moyens projets les uns et les autres
pensent pas qu'ils avaient imaginé
autonomie d travail et c'est très
important parce que ce qui est très
important chez marx et je pense dans une
tradition marxiste c'est de dire que le
travailleur doit posséder un savoir
faire une compétence et pouvoir
l'exercer de manière autonome or les
travailleurs des plateformes si vous
leur enlever leurs téléphones portables
ils ne peuvent rien faire mais bon sang
ce qui a changé dans la société non non
non est ce que je peux faire sans mon
téléphone mais non mais là c'est
l'intermédiaire qui leur donne du mal
dans leur dos
si je maintiens mes taxes mardon pardon
doit
jouer qui est du débat entre vous dans
dans mes jeux débats sur version sans
produit bien il dit il ya des
auto-entrepreneurs heureux et il y en a
plus qu'on le croit il dit sont même
majorité avait alors déjà quand alors je
peux déjà vous donner leurs revenus ça
calmera un petit peu l'enthousiasmé de
l'état durant 90 % des
auto-entrepreneurs depuis la mise en
place du régime gagne moins que le smic
et pourtant ce n'est que du chiffre
d'affaires c'est à dire qu'il faut
encore retirer les cotisations sociales
des éventuelles charges liées à
l'activité un loyer une voiture à
rembourser et s'est il imposé
et les chiffres d'affaires sont
descendus à 315 euros par mois au moment
de la crise alors
au net vous devriez reconnaître aussi
que depuis que ce statut a été créé
régulièrement les revenus des
auto-entrepreneurs progresse c'est
indiscutable dans les chiffres ils vont
aller que dans quelques mois il y aura
ce sera à peu près au niveau du smic et
vous reconnaîtrez leur fragilité s'agit
d'une et bien sûr qui c'est la raison
pour laquelle leur sang pour
l'amélioration de la protection sociale
que nous avions mis ça n'est pas vrai de
dire qu'il n'y avait pas de protection
sociale c'est encore un abus de langage
qui dit que le statut de l'auto
entrepreneur a été créé il a été prévu
des droits à la retraite
une couverture maladie le vrai sujet
c'est que l'intermittence de l'activité
des auto entrepreneurs ouvrez peu de
droits à la retraite etc cette anormal
que lorsque un auto entrepreneurs
travaillent dans les mêmes conditions
qu'un salarié ne bénéficient pas les
mêmes droits protection du cheval a
changé payer ils n'ont pas de chômage
ils ont des relents extrêmement fait et
vu de leur chiffre d'affairé là où on a
une divergence de fond parce que la
philosophie de l'indépendant n'est pas
la même que la philosophie du salarié un
indépendant dans une vision très
classique il n'a pas à se préoccuper ou
plus exactement il n'a pas à se
préoccuper lorsqu'il perd des clients ou
qu'il a
un chiffre d'affaires ou qu'il a une
impossibilité de travailler il est
indépendant il doit l'assumer simplement
on n'avait pas prévu la pandémie mais ça
c'est un vrai choc que des indépendants
ont vu disparaître tous leurs clients
d'un coup alors donc il ya une
couverture pdl va être amélioré sur le
chômage
alors juste à être mises en place dont
le socle des droits à l'élévation à
l'augmentation de la protection sociale
des indépendants augmente bon
vélo v dit parce qu on va détailler
après dans le débat ce qu'on peut
améliorer à ce statut pour que cette de
toute façon c'est ce mouvement il va pas
s'arrêter indue du jour au lendemain
donc la question c'est comment on peut
l'encadré mais je voudrais rentrer dans
le détail olivier jacquin de ce rapport
de cette mission d'information
parlementaire avec quentin calme est
journaliste à la rédaction de public
sénat bonsoir quand tu as donc on en a
trop pensé à à l'évoquer mais
effectivement il y a un travail qui a
été mené au sénat sur cette question de
la plateforme isation oui effectivement
tome 1 ça rapporte très récent puisqu'il
a été remis il ya une quinzaine de jours
voilà vous le montrer monsieur jacquin
qui effectivement dire en bon français
un qui parle de plateforme isation non
dubé réalisation avec deux constats nous
qu'on a retenue à la lecture de ce
rapport tout d'abord c'est effectivement
qu'il ya une grande évolution on parlait
au début des transports quand on parlait
de la formulation et maintenant on voit
que ça c'est en a beaucoup de secteurs
de l'économie et pas que des secteurs
marchands thomas les sénateurs avaient
entendu des architectes des traducteurs
des experts comptables et même des
services à la personne et des ressources
humaines donc on voit cette énorme
échantillon de métier et dans leurs
rapports deuxième constat les sénateurs
ont vraiment appelés à encadrer ce
qu'ils appellent un management
algorithmics est à dire que pour les
sénateurs ses calculs à ses algorithmes
produisent désormais je cite une
véritable chaîne de donneurs d'ordres et
c'est ça aussi que vous vouliez soutenir
dans votre rapport écoutez le rapporteur
et le communiste pascal calvel délits
sur l'importance de ces algorithmes
c'est fabien hecquet qui l'avait
interrogé dans son documentaire ses
algorithmes personne en a la maîtrise et
ceux qui déterminent vos conditions de
travail vont re s'ouvre première vous
êtes rémunéré voilà l'algorithme c'est
ce qui fait la la nature et la relation
de l'activité c'est extrêmement
important donc dans la dans le projet de
loi que nous avions déposé le groupe
communiste républicain l'écologiste et
citoyens nous avions mis dans nos toiles
le fait que tous ces travailleurs
puissent avoir data scientiste 1,8 data
scientiste s'il ya quelqu'un qui est
capable de décortiquer
l'algorithme donc de comprendre comment
s'organise l'activité qui décide comment
ça se décide et à quelles conditions
donc c'est un enjeu extrêmement
important il faut une transparence voilà
et on a retenu d'autres recommandations
dans votre travail messieurs les
sénateurs on avait vu par exemple l'idée
d'avoir les mêmes garanties du droit du
travail quand les travailleurs des
plateformes sont exposés à des risques
professionnels également l'idée
d'organiser un dialogue social entre à
l'appel former ses salariés alors on
sait que c'est quelque chose qui est
dans les tuyaux que le gouvernement veut
lancer en janvier prochain eh bien vous
faisiez beaucoup de deux dites vous
donner beaucoup d'idées dans votre
rapport sur comment encadrer ce dialogue
social et enfin on le voit un favoriser
la transparence de ses algorithmes cette
nuit sur l'information avec ses
conclusions pour les sénateurs c'était
vraiment un moyen de lancer une alerte
c'est ce qu'avaient dit les sénateurs au
nom de la remise du rapport merci
beaucoup quentin il faut souligner que
c'était un rapport aux remontrances
partisans puisque tout reporter et
communistes et son épouse martine
berthet
il faut saluer le fait qu'il était votée
à l'unanimité
il était votée à l'unanimité parce qu'on
n'a pas parlé de la question qui fâche
est le statut vous voyez ce sur quoi on
vient de s'écharper quelque peu par
contre le fait qu'ils aient unanimité ça
veut dire l'ensemble de la
représentation sénatoriales est d'accord
pour tirer une sonnette d'alarmé pour
dire il faut réguler il faut mieux
contrôler certaines dérives tout à fait
excessive et c'est ça que je tiens à
saluer avec comme vous venez de le dire
à un effort particulier à faire sur ce
qu'on appelle le management
algorithmique alors c'est quoi cette
idée cette idée de d'algorithmes ans
pourquoi les les algorithmes ont un
impact sur le final mans le travail
quotidien et sur le statut de ces
sarah vous l'a dit
le patron dans ces activités là c'est le
téléphone portable qui vous envoient des
consignes qui sur lequel on met des
notations qui peut vous déconnecter le
syndicat devait essayer nv a fait une
enquête impressionnante sur la
déconnexion dans les chauffeurs chez les
chauffeurs de venez sélecter on est viré
on est viré on est viré et les motifs
c'est incroyable vous avez des gars qui
ne savent même pas les raisons de leur
déconnexion et qui n'ont plus de boulot
du jour au lendemain c'est assez
incroyable c'est une drôle de boîte
noire qui est protégé par le secret de
fabrication
il ya beaucoup de matière grise dedans
et nous ce que l'on dit il faut la
réguler je vais sortir prochainement des
propositions
cela simplifie en gros de la même
manière qu'au siècle précédente on a mis
dans les cabines des camionneurs des
mouchards les chronotachygraphe pour des
raisons de sécurité évidentes pour pas
que les gars travaille 20 heures par
jour et vous écrase avec leurs camions
eh bien je vais faire des propositions
sur l'idée d'un algorithme public qui
viendraient contrôler certains éléments
de l'algorithme privés en mettant en
avant la cnil qui a un grand savoir
faire dans ce domaine plutôt que
d'inventer une nouvelle autorité qui
vont mettre des années à sa culture et à
devenir
compétentes et en même temps parce qu'il
faut pas casser l'innovation il faut
imaginer avec ses algorithmes qui sont
auto après dans les évolue presque tout
seul qu'il y ait un autocontrôle des
plateformes numériques c'est à dire que
dès qu'on leur signalerait un biais un
problème eh bien elle devrait réagir
denis jacquet je pense que vous
continuez de nous entendre et pouvoir
participer aux débats cette question des
algorithmes et cette proposition que
fait le sénateur jacques est à chacun
est ce que ça vous prend à jacquet
jacques un pardon qu'est ce que ça vous
semble
liste tout simplement vu l'état du
marché vu la berri rang international
sur trets des affaires liberté
d'entreprendre
c'est pas c'est pas super évident en
fait beaucoup de gens ont confondu le
fait qu'on monte l'observateur du bea
session avec le fait qu'on veuille la
défendre non or à l'époque nous aussi on
est à jouer avec nous s'est il ya cinq
ans qu'on a fait ce travail donc on a
fait très tôt on avait laurent
grandguillaume un ps qui étaient avec
nous on avait frais avec lefebvre on
avait des syndicalistes on a vraiment
rassembler à peu près toute la société
une soixantaine de plateformes donc le
problème de lag au rytme le problème de
la data est de savoir comment
fonctionnent les boîtes est de savoir
comment on déconnecte quelqu'un
ça peut avoir un intérêt mais très
honnêtement comment vous allez allez
changer véritablement le système sur des
petites mesures comme ça elles sont
intéressantes je dis pas qu'elles sont
pas intéressantes mais le débat il est
beaucoup plus globale cirque elle est
notre économie vers quoi le consommateur
de ce qu'on dit c'est hubert cd livres
ou mais non c'est le consommateur qui
dit que cette économie aujourd'hui bon
quand il a une offre il a accepté il
adoubé c'est notre société tout entière
je suis sûr que parmi nous autour du
plateau beaucoup utilisent ces vtc ou
ces taxis et on n'arrête pas de se
focaliser sur un métier des vtc alors
que je vous rappelle juste que taxis g7
et taxis bleus ça à 30 ans se sont pas
des salariés ils sont derrière une
plateforme qui leur attribuer des
courses et on n'a jamais pensé à faire
tout ce excusez moi ce cinéma autour de
7,2 cette rue qu'ils étaient eux aussi
alors précarisés pour consommer pas
occupé il ya 30 ans et pendant ce temps
là il n'y avait pas eu peur mais taxis
g7 taxis bleus qui s'en est mis plein
les poches sur le dos des taxis et
personne n'a jamais réagi d'aussi j'ai
beaucoup de mal à contrôler s'assurant
cette surenchère avec le taxi juge
revient à thomas si vous voulez juste
trois mots très rapide 1 le fait que les
gens soient moins bons piliers mais je
sais plus c'est madame qui disait tout à
l'heure c'est totalement faux et en
prenant l'ensemble des auto
entrepreneurs forcément c'est des gens
qui jongle sur plusieurs trucs sur la
plupart des professions de moyennes
moyennes ou thé haute qualification de
l'esthéticienne jusqu'au consultants ils
sont mieux payés que dans le salariat ce
qui leur permet effectivement d'avoir
moins de droits parce qu'il cumule plus
d'argent vous pouvez être 60 ans
servir dans un restaurant en france
protégés par ce magnifique droit du
travail est toujours être à 2000 euros
ici où je vis à miami le serveur ici au
minimum il ya une 6000 $ par mois alors
ils m'ont a moins de droits mais il
gagne quatre fois plus donc du coup la
première chose ce mythe de la
précarisation sur le salaire est faux
est au tout début de l'arrivée des vtc
je vous rappelle que le salaire moyen en
france je crois aux alentours de 2300 et
quelques les chauffeurs de deux
premières années de numérisation était
au dessus de 2800 euros par mois donc en
fait ils gagnaient mieux qu'un salarié
la deuxième chose c'est que moi la seule
précarisation que je connaisse c'est
celle du chômage donc au lieu de salaire
tu est de savoir si quelqu'un travaille
dans quelles conditions ce qui est
légitime c'est déjà de se posent la
question depuis 30 ans pourquoi on un
chômage de masse qu'on n'arrive pas à
résorber avant de se poser cette
question dont quelque chose qui vous
apporte un travail ça mérite un petit
peu d'attention la troisième la
subordination s'il vous plaît et je
finis par ça lassus born in their
arrêter avec ça je suis entrepreneur
depuis 25 ans vous savez ce que c'est
qu'un entrepreneur en france dont 70 %
des cas il a un donneur d'ordre et quand
s'il s'appelle ou michel edouard leclerc
ou autre il fait de vous ce que vous
voulez donc si vous voulez requalifiés
en salaires en c1 en salariés
aujourd'hui les vtc les indépendants ont
requalifié deux millions et demi
d'entrepreneurs en france parce qu'on
est totalement subordonnée non pas une
plate forme mais à des gens qui
connaissent nos coûts nos trucs et c'est
facebook
invité sur se placer
oui oui c'est peut-être de rétablir
certaines certaines choses sur les
revenus des chauffeurs hubert oui les
statistiques de l'insee disent qu'ils
gagnent en moyenne 470 euros par mois
contre 1230 pour les taxis donc c'est
aussi pour ça même si évidemment on
pourrait revenir sur le mouvement de
plateforme isation un peu des grandes
compagnies de taxis dans les années
soixante dix qui ont porté préjudice à
un peu à l'autonomie des taxis donc on
pourrait aussi en parler mais là on a un
mouvement massif qui s'est développée
dans un certain nombre dans d'autres
professions on a un vrai voilà
contournement un peu organisés du modèle
social donc effectivement oui il se
passe autre chose que ce qui s'est passé
de manière un peu ponctuels pour les
taxis les revenus des chauffeurs hubert
quand les plateformes s'installe elles
ont des politiques de fidélisation de la
main d'oeuvre elles vont chercher à
attirer le plus possible de chauffeur et
le plus possible de clients pour obtenir
une pause une position de monopole sur
le marché et après elles dégradent les
conditions de rémunération des
chauffeurs des livreurs elles ont toutes
fait donc effectivement au début on peut
sans doute prendre une petite période ne
sais pas d'où vient ce chiffre je pense
qu'il est sans doute contestable mais
une petite période pendant laquelle ils
avaient des revenus supérieurs le
problème c'est que très vite après les
plateformes diminue le prix de la course
minimum les plates formes de livraison
de repas arrête le paiement à l'heure
pour passer au paiement à la course il
ya de plus en plus de chauffeurs et deux
livreurs ils sont en concurrence les uns
avec les autres les revenus se dégradent
énormément et leurs êtres sociale
s'arrête parce qu'il faut bien voir que
et c'est ce que laurent grandguillaume
disait c'est plate forme elle fonctionne
sur elles sont subventionnés en fait par
l'état parce que la plupart des
chauffeurs et des livreurs touchent des
allocations sociales d allocation de
retour à l'emploi des minima sociaux il
touche la craint led qui permet qui leur
évite des cotisations sociales mais là
c'est aussi un énorme débat comment
financer la protection sociale de ces
travailleurs alors que les plateformes
cotisent 0 et que eux mêmes pour leur
faire gagner un peu plus d'argent on les
allège aussi des cotisations sociales ou
l'accordéon
je voudrais réagir parce qu'on peut pas
demander est-ce que vous avez changé
d'avis par rapport au moment où vous
étiez dans cet enjeu est libéral je les
ai dit je vais contre le modèle de
l'état providence et jamais au texas je
vais vous répondre
on peut pas plaider deux choses à la
fois à savoir la précarisation
incessantes des chauffeurs livreurs d'un
côté et les aides sociales dont il
bénéficie ça va pas ensemble
il faut que vous choisissiez l'un ou
l'autre des arguments peut pas dire que
on assiste à une précarité grandissante
et en même temps ils touchent la crds il
toucherait les nominations
du doigt cette petite contradiction et
ses peines et la deuxième ciné soupe
quand on touche le rsa et qu'on est
livreur à vélo aprilia sûr mais enfin la
précarité il chémeré liens des
élargisseurs outre opposé avait novelli
pour encore améliorer
développé en trois minutes je voudrais
vous ne mangerez ce que
je regrette que le débat se soit
focalisée sur les chauffeurs livreurs on
a beau parler que d'eux parce que non
mais quand on ramène au chauffeur
livreur c'est la classe la plus fragile
dans le monde et bien sûr c'est pour ça
que je milite pour l'amélioration de la
protection sociale des indépendants
depuis depuis que je préside
l'association des plateformes
d'indépendance est inscrit dans le
marbre cette amélioration de la
protection sociale en tout cas je milite
pour on peut donner ses prêts ses
complices est revenu le brave la nie et
falcon du statut le plus fragile des
indépendants à savoir les chauffeurs
d'un côté les vtc et livreur pour
discréditer cette plateforme isation qui
est porteuse de valeur ajoutée et
d'activité parce que si les indépendants
progresse dans ce pays comme y progresse
partout dans le monde sait que sûrement
qu'il ya à l'est des raisons un mot des
raisons objectives et je regrette cette
carrie comment comment améliorer la
protection sans casser la croissance de
de ce secteur est quand même de notre
économie mais j'ai entendu des propos
qui sont à peine acceptable par les deux
mythes de la précarité mais que ce
monsieur reviennent de miami et viennent
dans les rues de paris dans les vies
dans les rues des villes françaises
voire des travailleurs migrants sans
papiers dans des conditions illégales
insupportable mais c'est pas possible
d'entendre des contrevérités de cette
manière là je ne suis pas contre le
travailleur indépendant je suis
agriculteur je suis un vrai travailleur
indépendant si les moyens de ma
protection sociale quand je vendrai mon
tracteur j'aurai une retraite le livre à
vélo quand il aura vendu son vélo il
aura rien
de droit est actuellement
certains sont exonérés du droit du
travail on a une cour suprême en france
s'appelle la cour de cassation qui l'y a
dit ceux ci sont des indépendants
fictifs il devrait être salarié et
qu'est ce que fait le gouvernement
rien rien et protège les plates formes
plutôt que les travailleurs des
plateformes et donc ça n'a rien d'un
côté amélioration du statut d
indépendant de l'autre et il ya de quoi
faire je vais citer la plateforme
gorillaz qui est un nouvel entrant en
france qui fait du quick commerce il
région de course à domicile rien n'y en
a plusieurs voilà il y en a plusieurs et
c'est parce que je viens de les
rencontrer et eux ils disent le statut
des livreurs est tellement dégradée dans
l'image des gens nous on a besoin de
fidéliser notre clientèle et on les a
embauchés en cdi dont il s'est donc
cette fois ci le jeu ce qu'ils y sont en
revanche aussi puisqu'il ya dans le nom
il ya des plateformes non par le haut il
ya des plateformes qui se singularise en
disant nous on sale arino
dj stitch vous serez livrés par un
travailleur en cdi et qui en cas de
problème en cas de crise aura un salaire
différé par une protection sociale et
finira pas au rsa si ce n'est pas ça me
semble c'est que ça passe toujours par
la justice pour améliorer le modèle
exactement qu'on a tous exactement on a
tous admis ce modèle de plateforme
lisation son atom et pourquoi la justice
doit passer pour améliorer stationnement
le politique a un rôle puisqu'il doit
suivre le mouvement de la société et le
politique doit accompagner et notamment
empêcher les entreprises d'imposer ce
statut parce que ça c'est un fait et
dire aussi qu autant entrepreneurs on
cumule on peut dire aussi merci beaucoup
à tous d'avoir participé à ce débat je
rappelle le titre de votre livre les
nouveaux travailleurs des applis très
bon livre dominique méda c'est aux
presses universitaires de france et je
vais aussi signalé denis jacquet public
au vide début de la peur fin d'une
démocratie c'est chez eyrolles voilà
demain 8 heures l'invité politique
dorian nancy nice est olivier dussopt le
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics merci encore à tous d'avoir
participé à ces débats